Và phúc tầm Thế Parry ngày hai mai tháng năm đã tuyên hẳng sản xuất mấy bài Averse và hẳng không Aference phạm tổ in ngộ sát
dưới nghiệp, linh quan tế vụ dân chuyển bài A, bụng bài chính đại tây dương, năm hành nhiên
không trong lấy chính, khó răng tình vào tên bà ấy về đu tiên phản quyết mời đá báo bỏ quý định
năm hành nhiên không trai bài của tuán cấp dưới, bốn tuyên 2 công tý vô tội, giòn theo bằng trứng về anh
đi xưa xuất giẫn tới thảm hả?
Truyên bài A, bốn bài của Aference, thời hành tự vô đu jen roll tới Parry đã lâu xuống đại tây dương và ngày 1 tháng 6
năm hành nhiên không trong lấy chính, khiến toàn bộ hai chơi mười só hành khách và mời hai thành viên phíang quan thiệt mạc.
Thưa kêu luận đu cháan toàn thông phá ngăn hành nhiên không trong mấy một, tán đã sử dây ra xấu khi ông Pitov bị đông băng,
là mất tính hiểu tông đầu khiến phi công sự li không chính xác và mấy bài dưa bởi tình trạng mất lực nân khi đồng học.
Giờ đến kênh những trường rằng Averse và Aference phải chú chính nghiệp vì lỗi tiếp biển và công tá đảo tạo chơi đại đủ.
Chúc khi đau lột sinh của họ, Averse, ông Sa Minh Li đầy về trường biết,
tập đoàn sẽ khăn cáo lên toàn tự cao phá, trường rằng phán quét không cực cơ sở pháp li đại đủ.